LOOK AT THAT.
AINSLEY: ETHICS EXCITING.
THANKS, CARLEY.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
BIG NEWS THIS MORNING IN THE
RACE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS VACCINE
THE DRUGMAKER ME MO CONCERN THAT
ASKING THE FDA FOR EMERGENCY
APPROVAL OF ITS VACCINE TODAY.
HERE TO REACT IS THE AUTHOR OF
THAT BOOK RIGHT THERE "MAKE
AMERICA HEALTHY AGAIN"
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
THIS IS EXCELLENT NEWS.
CAN YOU TILL US ALL ABOUT IT?
>> VERY EXCITING NEWS THIS
MORNING.
MODERNA HAS OFFICIALLY GOING TO
FILE TODAY THEIR UEA WITH THE
FDA ABOUT THEIR COAST VACCINE.
THEY ARE REPORTING A 94%
EFFICACY RATE.
ONE OF THE MORE IMPORTANT THING
THAT THEY ALSO SAID IT WAS
100 PERCENT EFFECTIVE IN
PREVENTING SEVERE ILLNESS SUM
SIMILAR TO THE FLU SHOT.
GET THE FLU VACCINE AND STILL
GET THE FLU BUT DOES A GREAT JOB
IN MAKING SURE IT’S NOT THE
SEVERE EFFECTS OF THE FLU AND
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE MODERNA IS
GOING TO BE THE SAME WITH
COVID-19.
THAT’S ANOTHER WAY TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
AINSLEY: THAT’S GREAT.
THE FDA IS MEETING ON
DECEMBER 10TH TO TALK ABOUT
PFIZER.
WILL THEY ALSO BE TALKING ABOUT
MODERNA OR WILL THAT BE A
SEPARATE PANEL?
>> IT WILL BE A SEPARATE PANEL.
RIGHT NOW THE FDA IS REVIEWING
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT PFIZER
HAS SUBMITTED.
ON DECEMBER 10TH THEY ARE GOING
TO CONVENE AND DOING A
NONBINDING VOTE TO SEE IF IT
ACTUALLY SHOULD GET APPROVED
FROM THE EUA OR NOT.
A COUPLE DAYS BEFORE
DECEMBER 10TH WEE HAVE A GOOD
IDEA IF IT WILL BE APPROVED OR
NOT AS THE STAFF REPORT COMES
OUT.
THEY WILL BE SUBMITTING THE
DOCUMENTS ONLINE SO IT’S
AVAILABLE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTARY.
THAT IS CRUCIAL TO GET RID OF
SOME OF THIS SKEPTICISM THAT’S
BEING PRESENT WITH THE PUBLIC
RIGHT NOW.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
PROCESS IS TRANSPARENT, WHICH
IT’S GOING TO BE.
AINSLEY: I KNOW THE CDC IS GOING
TO MEET THIS WEEK TO DISCUSS WHO
IS GOING TO BE VACCINATED FIRST.
I’M SURE WE YOU HAVE BACK ON TO
TALK ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS DR. SALEEN GODDER.
SHE IS ON THE COVID ADVISORY
BOARD.
LISTEN TO THIS, NICOLE AND WE
WILL GET YOUR REACTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> WE FULLY EXPECT THAT IN ABOUT
A WEEK OR TWO AFTER
THANKSGIVING, WE WILL SEE AN
INCREASE IN CASES FIRST.
THEN ABOUT A WEEK OR TWO LATER
YOU WILL START TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS.
AND THEN ANOTHER WEEK OR TWO
AFTER THAT YOU WILL START TO SEE
DEATHS.
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY, THAT MEANS
THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO CELEBRATED
WITH FAMILY, WITH FRIENDS OVER
THANKSGIVING WILL FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE HOSPITAL IN
ICUs OVER CHRISTMAS AND NEW
YEAR’S.
AINSLEY: DR. SAPHIER DR. BIRX
SAID ASSUME YOU HAVE IT IF YOU
TRAVELED FOR THANKSGIVING.
>> SO.
THAT’S RIGHT.
ANXIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN
SAYING NOW FOR A COUPLE MONTHS
AND I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD BE A
TRANSLATOR FOR DR. FAUCI AND NOW
DR. GOUNDER EVEN THOUGH WHAT SHE
IS SAYING IS NOT TRUE.
MAKE SURE WE ARE NOT PUSHING
PEOPLE AWAY TO WANTING TO
ADHERE.
DR. FAUCI SAID MAYBE WE SHOULD
CANCEL CHRISTMAS.
IS THAT TRUE MOST RIDICULOUS
THING POSSIBLE.
MANY SAFE WAYS TO BE TOGETHER
FOR CHRISTMAS.
WHILE DO I AGREE WE HAD OVER
9 MILLION AMERICANS TRAVEL
DURING THE THANKSGIVING TIME
THAT WILL UNDOUBTEDLY RESULT IN
A RISE IN CASES WHICH WILL
RESULT IN A RISE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND WILL RESULT
IN A RISE FOR DEATH.
WE HAVE UNCONTROLLED SPLEFD THE
COUNTRY.
ALTHOUGH THE MAJORITY WILL NOT
DIE FROM IN THIS IS STILL A
DEADLY VIRUS.
WE HAVE A FEW MORE MONTHS OF
THIS.
PFIZER IS GOING TO LIKELY
PRODUCE 20 MILLION VACCINES FOR
AMERICANS BY THE END OF 2020.
JUST GIVE IT A FEW MORE MONTHS.
IF YOU TRAVEL OVER THANKSGIVING
BREAK, I DO RECOMMEND ASSUMING
YOU HAVE THE VIRUS.
I RECOMMEND ASSUMING EVERYBODY
HAS THE VIRUS RIGHT NOW.
I THINK I HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT
SINCE THE SPRING.
DO WHAT CAN YOU.
WASH YOUR HANDS.
IF YOU TRAVELED OVER THE BREAK,
I WOULD CONSIDER GETTING TESTING
RIGHT NOW IF YOU DON’T WANT TO
SELF-QUARANTINE FOR 10 TO 14
DAYS AND KNOW THERE IS A BIG
LIGHT AT THE END OF THIS TUNNEL.
AINSLEY: YES.
CHRISTMAS IS AROUND THE CORNER.
THE BIRTHS OF OUR XAVIER AND